I suck at a lot of things oh what's that
oh no booze here oh here in bed are we
now
no cuz I'm the best at fucking sleeping
and when you suck people don't want to
tell you face to face it was good yeah I
mean I've never written a novel so oh
but if it's anonymous
they got this when you realize that you
suck there are two things that you can
do you can cry and give up or you can
strengthen your resolve to become better
it's so weird
cuz when we first start doing stuff yeah
we all kind of suck you call yourself a
crazy cat lady
you only have one cat poser it's not
till you practice and focus on improving
that you really get better I hope that
if you really love doing something you
keep going don't let others and
especially not yourself stop you from
trying to improve Anna please stop but
how am I supposed to get better if I
don't keep trying you suck so bad you're
embarrassing me yeah but maybe with
enough effort on oh that's what you're
doing no BAE I mean who knows where
you'll be a couple years down the road
if you really focus on getting better
now whatever it is you're passionate
about I mean for example my first day of
motorcycle class john-boy spelled the
bike many times
and it hurt very bad like I'm an
instructor yelled at me quite a bit but
now I have my motorcycle license so I
can hurt myself without the supervision
of a paid instructor if I can get my
motorcycle license anything is possible
seriously I'll see you next week stay
awesome Gotham